bonjour pierre henry merci de répondre à
nos questions arte france cet après midi
tout d'abord quelle est votre réaction
suite à cette plainte déposée donc par
utopia 56 qui s'ajoutent à celles
d'autres associations notamment du côté
britannique
mais je la comprends totalement il faut
se souvenir qu'il y à trois semaines 27
personnes ont perdu la vie dans la
manche et ils ont perdu la vie dans des
circonstances tout à fait particulière
certes les pacers ont une responsabilité
mais ces gens qui étaient sur un ratio
de fortune ont appelé les secours il ya
une règle absolue
en mer c'est que le sauvetage doit avoir
lieu on ne regarde pas les nationalités
des personnes on sauve les vies et puis
ensuite on voit éventuellement quelle
est leur situation
en l'occurrence il ya eu défaillance il
semble que les secours français et
britanniques se soient renvoyés la balle
que du côté français on est considéré
que les personnes se trouvaient dans les
eaux territoriales britanniques et donc
que c'était au britannique d'intervenir
manifestement d'après les témoignages
des rescapés
il semble que les britanniques et
oublier totalement de répondre à l'appel
au secours des personnes donc qu'il y
ait une enquête je pense que c'est
récent et
c'est absolument
nécessaire
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya déjà une
enquête 1 qui qui a été ouverte suite à
ce naufrage mais pour utopia 56 je cite
cette enquête se concentre
essentiellement sur les rôles des
passeurs alors qu'est ce que ça peut
changer cette plante est quelque chose
que cette plainte aboutisse non mais
d'abord moi je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas au coeur de l'enquêté je pense que
l'utopie ne l'est pas plus
il me semble qu'il faut faire la lumière
sur l'ensemble du processus évidemment
sur les personnes qui ont des
responsabilités
dans le fait d'armer des bateaux de
battre une quarantaine de personnes de
prendre de l'argent oui il est normal qu
alors parce que il y a inculpation dans
certain nombre de personnes a enquêté
sur ce volet là mais il est aussi normal
d'enquêter pour savoir s'il ya eu des
défaillances du système de secours et si
ces défaillances ont été volontaires
dans ce cas c est sa part encore bonnes
à un abandon en plein air et c'est un
acte qui pourrait bien être un criminel
mais ses talents quête de le dire donc
voilà je pense qu'il faut maintenant
laisser travailler les institutions
judiciaires
avec avec calme mais
la question n'est absolument pas résolu
entre la grande bretagne et la france et
d'autres passages ont lieu aujourd'hui à
bord
sans doute et donc la question il ya
quelques temps à calais au début du mois
entre paris berlin bruxelles amsterdam
londres n'a pas été convié
et cette réunion est bien convenu de
s'appuyer sur l' agence européenne de
gardes frontières frontex pour lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs comment
est ce que vous avez accueilli cette
décision mais cette décision est normal
que l'union européenne c'est un garde et
aux frontières c'est bien c'est bien
logique est donc comme la frontière
qu'elle essayait d une porte de sortie
de l'union européenne il est normal que
frontex se déploie mais enfin on va pas
régler le problème des migrations entre
la france et la grande bretagne de cette
manière je rappelle que la grande
bretagne a externalisé sur le sol
français c'est un politique mais rapport
et sa frontière donc ça ça pose un
véritable problème la grande bretagne ne
prend pas ça pas inquiète
mais au delà de réviser les accords du
touquet qui le sont eux mêmes de toute
façon déséquilibrée
il faut que la grande-bretagne prenne sa
place et moi j'ai toujours plaidé pour
des voies de migration légale entre la
grande bretagne et la france je rappelle
que les personnes qui réussissent la
traversée de la manche et qui
arrivent sur le territoire britannique
par la mère dépose pour la plupart
d'entre eux 95 % une demande d'asile et
vous savez quoi près de 60 % d'entre eux
sont reçus sont éligibles à l'aise il
alors franchement ya sans doute une
autre méthode à employer
des voies de migration légale pour faire
en sorte que la grande bretagne prennent
ça par les dans l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile parce que je rappelle que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire la grande
bretagne malgré le break suite à signer
la convention de genève et que cela
l'obligent merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'association
france fraternité